uh should move on to joey's stupidity
yeah yeah sure all right
let's prepare for one of the normiest
[ __ ] three dude i mean you've already
had my three by three
okay
okay okay okay
um uh let me ask
shocked by any of them so you're like a
death below
like completely normie then yeah we
haven't gone for final fantasy 7. well
no i think six is like the
the second normiest choice terraria yeah
dude
i didn't know terraria was like up in
your top nine okay terraria i've dead
ass
like if you go onto my steam i've
deadass play torreira for about 500
hours i was so
into toronto when i first came out like
we only talked about persona though
right
yeah i don't okay obviously
i don't really need to talk about breath
of the wild obviously um
why should marry wood out of all of the
marios okay super mario world for me
okay because
a lot of these games like especially the
older ones like um
kirby's nightmare and dreamland final
fantasy 6 and stuff like that yeah i got
them as hand-me-downs from my cousin
so like basically all the super nintendo
games and like especially like kirby
games especially
um yeah all hand-me-downs and super
mario world was one of the first
like mario games i had like properly sat
down yeah
knowing it was a mario game yeah like
you know there's like games when you're
like
really really young where it's just like
this is just a video game
but i don't know like what this is it's
just a fun thing that's on my screen
yeah yeah yeah but super mario world was
the one where i was like okay
i'm playing this knowing fully well that
this is a mario game and that i love
mario games and you can't you can't hate
on that that's literally like one of the
best games of
all time it is one of the best [ __ ]
platforms like it was a tie between
super mario world for me
because we can only choose one game per
franchise right obviously for a mario
game
hardest [ __ ] for me to choose but it was
a tie between super mario world and
yoshi's island
oh yoshi's island i [ __ ] love you i
was like both of them are like
equal number one for me right um but i
ign top games of all yeah
honestly except for clan ads
that's like joey's like individualized
yeah for me was just like okay that's
what like really sold me
like animating out of everything on here
that like
well i that will make it known that it's
a joey list it's clannad yeah
if you remove that like i literally have
no idea have you removed clan ed it's
like oh i see you were also born in the
90s
you've typed in top wii game top ps5
game
top top game boy game top nsnes game
and then you've been like i'll have
those i'll have those yeah okay wait
wait which which super mario is it where
there's like there's a level where
there's a sun
trying to kill you that's super mario
brothers 3. i had nightmares of that
really that song i couldn't beat it and
i kept i kept having nightmares yeah
dude that game's [ __ ] hot like that
level is [ __ ] hard yeah have you have
you guys ever played the original mario
yeah
yeah yeah i think i think i've actually
played every mainline mario game because
[ __ ] nintendo re-releases it every
[ __ ] year
pay me 10 bucks for the same [ __ ]
game and i'm like okay did you play as a
kid
yeah okay as a kid did you want to eat
the [ __ ] chocolate the bricks
was that just me no
[Laughter]
but like yeah as a kid i remember i i
have a distinct memory of just
looking at the bricks and just thinking
man those look delicious
they kind of look like chocolate that is
definitely like i hope you didn't say
that out loud because your parents were
like oh god
oh [ __ ] we should we should take this
game away
oh god all right that's just me okay my
life
much like gaunt right i i think my three
by three is a little bit of a lie
because there's a bunch of games on here
because to me i was like okay
for me through and through i was always
a nintendo sim
yeah nintendo seemed from the moment i
got my first game console to today
yeah but because of that i feel i've
kind of put too many nintendo games on
my 3x3 i mean i mean like it's
it's it's it's the first thing that came
to your mind right yeah